I've been experiencing severe hot flashes at night, especially, along with all the other nasty
metaposal symptoms. I saw that Christi Northrip has a product called a Rome
abata made with an herb called mereria, verica. I can't pronounce that, sorry. Are you
familiar with this herb? And if so, is it okay to take with hormone positive breast cancer?
I am not taking black colhash or astro clear, only your other product with dim and calcium
de-glutering. I am familiar with that herb, even though I can't pronounce it. And it has been
used for people with hot flashes, and the reason why it can help is it can stimulate estrogen
production in your adrenal glands. Now, if you have hormone positive breast cancer,
that's not what you want to do. It would probably help with hot flashes,
as well as black colhash can help with hot flashes. But the whole purpose of trying to
the whole purpose of measuring whether you have a hormone positive cancer and trying to treat it
as a help to reduce your cancer, is to reduce estrogens. And if you're taking something that will
increase your estrogens, and thereby decrease the severity of the hot flashes, no matter how unpleasant
they may be, you're kind of going against what you're trying to do for the breast cancer. So I guess
I can't recommend that. You know, there may be other doctors that, no, estrogens have nothing to do
on the care of your estrogen positive breast cancer. Estrogen, nothing to do with it. I know doctors who
even give a prescription for hormone replacement therapy to people who have hormone positive cancer.
To me, that makes no sense whatsoever. And I would never do that. So you're welcome to do what you
want to do, but I wouldn't do anything that's going to increase your estrogens. And I never experience
hot flashes. So I apologize for not taking into consideration the emotional issues with the hot
flashes, but your whole purpose is try to slow the cancer.